The rising tide of radical Islam.
This dangerous ideology seeks to impose
itself on our society. You need us. You
need the immigrants. Don't speak in a
position of privilege as if we can't
have it. You actually need the
immigrants.
>> Paul Golding, you are [screaming] next.
>> On June the 28th, history is made.
Muhammad Hijab undefeated. Two fights,
two finishes. A 100% finish rate forged
in the heavyweight professional
rankings. Paul Golding, two wins, two
losses, stepping into the most
scrutinized fight of his career. This is
an ideological grudge years in the
making. Now settled under the
heavyweight MMA rules. The most
ideologically charged matchup the UK has
ever seen. Two worlds colliding inside a
cage. This is the fight the whole
country will be watching.